this is a production of Cornell
University
so hello everyone I'm gonna speak today
a bit about my master's thesis work on
the evaluation and improvement of dry
beans for regional staple crop
production here in the northeastern
United States okay so very briefly there
are two centers of domestication and
common bean as well as various eco
Geographic races within them some of
these races are represented by our
modern bean market classes between these
races we see various divergences in
morphology phonology and resistances to
abiotic and biotic stress for example
the middle American race Durango which
includes modern-day pintos is adapted to
arid hot environments while the indian
race nova granada that includes candy
kidney beans is better adapted to short
seasons and cooler environments so
crossing between races is a useful tool
for improving adapted traits
however some recent work has shown that
greatly reduced diversity within modern
market classes has occurred compared to
the domesticated gene pool as a whole so
this indicates that fewer crosses are
being made between races and this is in
part due to very specific seed quality
traits that are required by the
processing industry which is the
predominant market for dry beans here in
the US and this issue has been cited by
breeders as an obstacle to breeding
progress in particular within andean
races such as kidney
sorry okay okay
so why beans in the Northeast well first
the benefits of regional food production
and diverse crop rotation systems to
those both economic and ecological
health are well documented breeding and
market effort market development efforts
here in the Northeast have in the past
ten years increasingly focused on small
grains in particular specialty markets
such as bakeries breweries and
distilleries but those efforts have not
yet occurred for grain legumes which is
a potential rotation crop in that system
in addition in countries of the global
north such as the United States lack
lack of access to healthy food tends to
be more of a problem than access to food
calories overall and this has created a
public health crisis in our country and
other Western countries we see at the
same time increased consumer interests
in healthful foods as well as increased
concern for environmental impacts of
food production for example the carbon
footprint of meat consumption so all of
these trends point to a need for beans
that capture consumer interests as well
as a wider array of markets
so what are research questions first we
want to know what the obstacles are to
current regional driving production
second does regional production
including organic production have
distinct needs for variety development
and third can the development of
varieties outside of market classes
better meet the needs for regional
production
so what are our strategies first
strategy is to make sure that our
program is meeting actual needs by
engaging with stakeholders that means
assessing grower and supply chain means
as well as opportunities second is to
evaluate cultivars and potential
breeding material in replicated research
station as well as on-farm trials and
third is the development of improved
cultivars to meet regional grower and
market needs and due to the nature of
regional supply chains this work
interestingly does not need to be
restricted by market class designation
which as I mentioned can be a
significant limiting factor in breeding
progress so for the needs assessment
stage the strategies we used were first
qualitative interview interviews with
growers processors distributors and
reiative retailers in the regional bean
supply chain second was a nationwide
grower survey targeting organic and
direct market producers and third of
course some literature reviews which
focused on particular on seed borne
pathogens as this is a common issue in
bean production in more temperate
climates such as ours
so one fairly recent phenomenon is
single variety marketing of heirloom dry
beans which I won't unpack and entirely
here but does represent a market trend
that we can work with to support
regional production especially in
countries such as the United States
where income levels are generally rather
high consumer choice is based on a
complex array of factors among them food
culture cooking quality aesthetics as
well as price and growers have
recognized this consumer demand and due
to price premiums the production of
heirloom cultivars has become
economically valuable even though often
these varieties have greatly reduced
yields and in our surveys grower also
cited some agronomic advantages to the
heirloom cultivars they're growing
growing especially in more northern
latitudes where much short maturity time
was very important so as I mentioned
seed borne pathogens are a significant
challenge in temperate being growing
regions these include being common
mosaic virus cotton bacterial blight
halo blight and anthracnose which tend
to be the most prevalent effective
effective resistance to these pathogens
is especially important in organic
production where seed treatments are
limited importantly most of the heirloom
cultivars I mentioned that we grow here
in in the Northeast are Andean races
that are highly susceptible to these
pathogens prior research has identified
sources of resistance in vulgaris germ
plasm as well as other phaseolus species
many of these resistances have been
introduced to elite lines that meet
agronomic and quality trait requirements
for a commercial production and we're
able to adapt available codominance
markers developed by the usda for
bacterial blight bee CMV and anthracnose
that will be useful to our program going
forward
so we conducted variety trials using a
random complete block design at Thompson
research farm as well as on-farm trials
in the mother-baby trial design and
these trials were used to evaluate
modern cultivars older cultivars
heirlooms and landraces commonly grown
here in the Northeast as well as
breeding lines with useful disease
resistances so USD KCB b15 possesses low
sight for resistance to the pathogens I
mentioned previously bacterial blight
and track nose and B CMV as well as halo
blight and has linked markers for these
loose eye
so we observed very significant
differences in susceptibility between
the resistant breeding line and some of
the heirloom cultivars from the
Northeast such as Jacob's cattle and we
were able to observe that in under
natural disease pressure in the field
last summer see BB 15 also demonstrates
appropriate maturity time for our region
as well as a bright growth habit and
relatively high yield so you also see
that some non market class older
cultivars such as candy and Stardust
demonstrated yield that was as good or
better as on this elite breeding line as
well as moderate though not high disease
resistance and this indicates that there
are cultivars out there that growers
might not know about but that might meet
their needs currently for commercial
production outside of conventional
market classes varieties in yellow were
selected for breeding work and we picked
Calypso and Jacobs cattle as they are
already grown widely in our region as
well as other regions of the United
States so they have significant consumer
recognition and could greatly be
improved with enhanced disease
resistance
you
so through our needs assessments we are
able to establish kind of a baseline of
consumer and grower facing treats that
will guide our breeding work going
forward I'm so these include on the
consumer and cooking quality as well as
being types that are bred for diverse
culinary uses color retention and
cooking is another one and in terms of
grower traits yield of course upright
architecture disease resistance
appropriate maturity time for the
Northeast as well as seedling vigor and
weed competitiveness were decided as the
most important traits for growers
we used a fairly straightforward mercury
assisted pedigree selection scheme for
this breeding project with the goal to
introduce disease resistance higher
yield and improved growth habit into the
Calypso and Jacobs cattle heirloom
cultivars using CBB 15 as the other
parents codominant snip markers were
used to select progeny with resistance
to bacterial blight and practice and
being common mosaic virus so the initial
goal was to essentially regain all the
seed traits of the heirloom and release
sort of an improved heirloom cultivar
which is still the plan but many other
interesting phenotypes that you can see
here have also emerged so we will
conduct F for progeny row selection this
field season and that wraps it up it's
been fun
thanks to my lab for all their help my
committee another faculty here at
Cornell whose have contributed input
very grateful to the public being
breeding community which is incredibly
willing to share advice and germplasm
also all the growers
processors and everyone who contributed
ideas as well as my funding sources USDA
nifA
and northeast sare
and you thanks okay
Christians are you doing questions do
you have a question you have a question
that Kristen do you see it yes okay
where all of the varieties you showed
and Ian or were some Mesoamerican so in
terms of our trials which i think is
probably what you're referring to Jeff
so all of these except for Orca which is
right here can you see my screen right
now
I'm not sure no no we see you you're not
sharing anymore right okay so yes there
predominate
mostly there Andean because that is what
is grown in the Northeast they tend to
be determinate and shorter season which
is kind of what's better adapted black
beans for example are Mesoamericans so
so we've been primarily working in
Andean but I think there's a lot of
potential to expand options in the
Mesoamerican gene pool too Thanks does
so does dry bean production in North
East require any specialized equipment
or cancer bean farmers grow dry beans
easily that's a really good question so
the smaller seeded types such as black
beans navy beans generally can be
planted and harvested with the same
combine as soybeans types like kidneys
and cranberries tend to be lower growing
so they're a type 1 determinant instead
of the upright type 2 so those generally
are harvested using a bean puller and
that actually is uprooting the plant and
then it's wind Road into a row and then
combined using a pickup head so it that
does generally require more specialized
equipment ok how many of those I did you
manage at once with marker-assisted
selection and how did you man and
managed population status to deal with
multiple traits so in so this mostly
refers to and up to population which I
grew last summer and so I was a I grew
at about 400 plants and I was selecting
for Tolosa for bacterial blight one
loose eye for BC and the eCos and
essentially what I do
did you know given that I had 400
progeny was to prioritize so BCS and the
is our you know major our gene resistant
so that was kind of the first
requirement
and I essentially selected for either
bacterial blight or you know paired with
be CMV or be CMV and anthracnose to kind
of improve my ability to to advance kind
of those lines thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu